because you brought it up i
uh tweeted recently but also just
i'm one of the things i'm really ashamed
of in my life is
i haven't really read almost any of the
sci-fi classics
really yeah so like i my whole journey
through reading was
through like the
literary philosophers that would say
like camus jesse dostoevsky
kafka like that place like that's a kind
of sci-fi world in itself
but it's it just
it creates a world in which the
the deepest questions about human nature
can be explored
i didn't realize this but the sci-fi
world is the same it just puts it in a
it like
removes it from any kind of historical
context where you can explore those same
ideas
in like space somewhere elsewhere in a
different time a different place
it allows you almost like more freedom
to like construct these artificial
things where you can just
do crazy uh crazy kind of human
experiments so
i'm now working through it uh the books
on my list are
the foundation series by isaac asimov
dune uh snow crash
by neil stevenson and ender's game like
you mentioned
uh that's just kind of and then so i
posted that and then of course like elon
musk
john uh carmack i don't know if you know
him creator of doom and quake
oh cool see they all pitched in these
nerds
these ultra nerds just started like
going like did these
uh you need to read this that and and
the other so
i've like started working out okay but
it seems like the list i've mentioned
holds up somewhat is there a book is
there sci-fi
books or series or authors that
that you find are just amazing maybe
another way to ask that is like
what's the greatest sci-fi book of all
time well i'd like to start by uh
sharing something that i
i'm embarrassed about is that i haven't
read anything
other than uh you know orson scott card
j.r tolkien uh frank herbert tolkien
yeah dude
yep yeah yeah i'm aware through
wikipedia and uh through
through surface reading of things that
like a book called the republic was
written once
um yeah there were some other mother
you're uh a prolific reader of wikipedia
articles well
or occasionally okay exactly in between
uh
whatever else it is that i waste my time
on but but yeah so
i also i should say i posted on reddit
questions for
uh ryan hall and there's like a million
questions
but like uh half of them have to do with
dune no not really but like
people bring up do i don't understand
why i did you mentioned doom before
well i actually actually have a showy
roll actually made us a ghee a dune
themed gee one time which i thought was
kind of cool i'll send you i'll give you
one we got extras
but uh actually to your to your point
actually this is a orson scott card
quote actually the writer of vendors
game um fiction because it's not about
somebody who actually lived in the real
world
always has the possibility of being
about oneself
and i think that's a neat thing because
i have heard you know
other people whom i respect and very
sharp people
actually every now and then dig their
heels and go i don't like fiction i only
like non-fiction it's more it's more
instructive and i would go i completely
disagree with that
i think we have a hard enough time
figuring out what happened at 7 11
three hours ago that let me tell you
what happened 600
years bc i'm like hey i'm interested but
don't tell me this isn't a story too
yeah there's a there's there's actu
there's factual components i have no
doubt
but we struggle sometimes to like i
guess what i like about
fiction is that you can tell me a story
it's all about people
i mean every night there's more and less
believable things um and i think dune
would be an unbelievably well written
in my opinion for to run you know what
do i know but i really like doing i'll
say that
well-written example of you know human
beings interacting with one another the
political components of that the
emotional the intellectual
the relationship components all of that
and uh i think that dune is neat because
it's a sci-fi novel but only in the
only in the loosest sense it's it's
really a story about
religion about group dynamics about
human potential
about um belief learning
politics governance ecology
it's uh the best stories remind me of
history the same way history hopefully
is not just a
a list of facts that i try to be able to
recall or factoids that i try to recall
but a story that i can understand and
and see how
how the threads of time kind of came
together and created certain things and
a lot of times like we say i'm like
how the heck is what's going on right
now or 100 years from now 100 years in
the past happened
and you can look back far enough if we
had accurate knowledge
if we had that like that hypothetical
perfect pool shot you know
at the beginning of time we would see an
unbroken chain of events that led us to
where we are
and and where we are will potentially
lead us to where we're going which is
again why hindsight's helpful but i
think it's neat like
i guess i really enjoy for instance a
book like dune and they're actually
making a movie out of it which i'm
i'm skeptical of to be honest because
it's it's going to be difficult to bring
that to the screen for a variety of
reasons but
there's at least 100 questions ask ryan
what do you think's about the new dune
movie
i am not enough of an authority to have
any sort of decent opinion but i guess
what i would say is so much of it goes
on in the character's mind like how much
of any of our
day is any lived experience as it were
is internal that
the majority how many times are people
walking around and you know they can you
like hey what do you see right now i'm
like oh oh well i see this picture i see
a wall hey there's lex
but really what i was paying attention
to was what was going on inside of my
head for a moment and almost the rest of
the world
tuned out and kind of dimmed and uh
yeah i guess um that i think that's
going to be a struggle to to any time
you want to bring that type of a written
story to
to a visual medium i think it's going to
be more difficult but
it'll be interesting it's definitely my
one of my favorite stories and it's been
it's honestly helped me become better at
life in my opinion better with martial
arts
and i think the the writer i think frank
herbert was absolutely brilliant whether
those were all his ideas which in
reality none of us or all of our good
ideas aren't ours we're a combination
maybe came up with something you're a
curator of other good ideas and
some things you barred from somewhere
without even realizing it but uh i think
the the way the messages and the themes
and the ideas that were conveyed
particularly in the original novel
or just absolutely brilliant is that the
is that to you one of the greats and and
the flip side of that like
or another way to ask that is like if
somebody's new to sci-fi is that
something you would recommend
that that is an entry point i'm not well
read enough in this sci-fi world i
haven't read a lot of like isaac
asimov's or anything like that but
i just i'll recommend dune i'll be an
obnoxious like evangelist for dune to
anyone who'll listen
okay so yeah i would strongly recommend
it
you